hello everyone and welcome to another
video on code tech tutorials
my name is matt and you're watching
a year in review oh no green screen
this is a this is a recent happening
this let's check out
the other stuff wait it's like any time
i just change the lighting a little bit
it just my cam is locked why is it doing
this
youtube being a youtuber is fun there's
no stress involved
well i think the main thing to look at
is just the growth
over this year has been phenomenal it
has been something spectacular
just the videos viewed along with
subscribers gain they tend to go hand in
hand so the graphs look about the same
but you can see from january 20th we
were starting to ramp up a tiny bit
since last year but i didn't even have a
thousand
subs at this point so like going from
like january 20
well it's january 2019 i was getting
around a thousand views a month
to january 2020 starting out at about 9
000 views a month which is super good
and then it ramped up
somehow amazingly hit up to almost 30k
and did a little dip there and started
going back up
and i got big plans for this year so
overall yeah the channel is
definitely trending up and that's really
good camera
you gotta stop camera this is gonna
drive me crazy
okay it was it's uh this gets me every
time i swear
the white balance this keeps coming
checked
and unchecked just stay the same
gonna use the same lighting you don't
have to keep switching white bounds
focus and exposure just stay the same i
thought i had these
and low light compensation
just just don't change if i move my hand
you don't have to change everything
camera jeez all right there we go much
better
no it's not much better it actually
looks not that great right now ah
i gotta fix this okay so i switched
my view uh here on
my youtube studio stuff to 365 days and
being honest the first
day of the new year it should give us a
pretty good recap of
last year my biggest video last year
was blender 2.9 video editing basics
guide
cool thanks second biggest video was
cmake tutorial episode one
and then my next biggest video was
blender video editing transformations
rotations keyframes fades images
and then episode two of cmake tutorial
so it was definitely this
this blender and cmake zorro that
probably carried the channel quite a bit
but i did have a lot of
random one-off videos how to create your
own dynamic link library
seem to do well um this video i
i don't get it i don't get why people
still watch this it's from january 2019
how to set up includes linkers libraries
on visual studio
sure i was kind of a new back then and i
was doing some things wrong
but like uh
wait let's just let's just take a peek
at this video real quick
and just just look at this like ratio 60
likes 69 dislikes people do not like
this video
now i don't know why i haven't really
like watched this video and tried to
figure out why exactly other than it's
kind of bad quality
and there's much better ways to do
libraries
so i did put first thing here an updated
version is available because i did make
a new one
and i also said just use vc package
manager it's easier and a link to that
but still to this day people are still
watching this extremely disliked video
and still asking me
how to do libraries oh i guess the
audio is way out of sync with the video
i didn't realize that
although i addressed it already i must
have forgot
so i don't know people still keep
watching it and asking me questions
about it and
just don't watch these other videos
instead it's
i don't know i don't really want i don't
want to take this video down just
because it seems to
actually it does seem to have still
helped some people but it is my most
disliked video
by far and uh it just keeps getting
views it just keeps getting recommended
and i don't know why they keep
recommending it if people
don't like it but apparently it's made
me 17 bucks over the years so
cool so yeah i guess that's another
thing i should talk about that is kind
of a big deal
the channel did get monetized and how
much have i made i'm sure a lot of you
are kind of wondering
well i've made about 500 in total and
that was just
from last year now that's not enough for
like one month of rent or anything like
that
but i mean maybe if you live in a really
cheap place but
it's better than nothing and it's really
awesome to get monetized that was a huge
deal i uh i definitely celebrated
if i just look at like let me just look
at revenue because i want to be clear i
want to be open with you guys about all
this stuff
i tend to make about three bucks a day
right now on ads and that's with like
200 videos so that's like
really actually not that much not as
much as it seems like
but it has gotten to the point with like
three to four bucks a day
being you know it's about 100 a month at
this point which
uh it's not enough to survive on or
anything but i intend
to make a lot of new videos this coming
year and
not just for the revenue it's mostly
because i enjoy the interaction i'd
to be perfectly honest i uh yeah i don't
think i'm ever really going to live off
this i guess
i might have some luck and be able to
but i don't expect you it would be the
dream to just be able to do this channel
support on patreon if you want to
support my dream because that's going to
make it happen a lot faster
i do have a goal over there once once i
hit some certain monthly amount
i will basically cease all my other
technical jobs and focus strictly on the
channel
and my own projects mostly relating to
the channel
so support on patreon link down below if
you want to help
with this journey and the new year but i
do plan on pay
posting two videos a week this entire
year so there's going to be 104
new videos this year this being
the very first one so thank you so much
for tuning in and don't forget to
subscribe and hit the bell if you want
to see all my future videos
i'm trying to take a little more time
with them make them a little better
but i'm not perfect i'm going to make
mistakes so i don't know
it's just you being youtube's being
doing youtube is weird is what i'm
trying to say it's uh
i i don't know how to explain it other
than it's just like
you can't win it just feels like you
can't win
uh sometimes because if you do
everything perfect
people are going to hate you for doing
it well if you do everything terribly
people are going to pay you and love you
for doing it terribly
there's really no winning you just have
to keep going so anyone else that's like
watching and thinking maybe i should
start a channel yeah
just do it and just keep going you're
going to get like a lot of
negative feedback and a lot of positive
feedback and it's really important to
mostly
ignore the negative feedback other than
to address whatever it says critically
to like i don't know definitely use it
to try to improve but you got to weed
out the ones that are just
being jerks because they're having a bad
day or something you just can't listen
to those people
there are a lot of good people out there
and i've met a lot of you and you're
great
so i just want to say really thank you
to all the people who watch
and if you're not subbed please do it's
it's a pretty high percentage of
unsubbed people that watch which you
know i i
don't really bring up but i guess in the
first video of the year i will bring it
up
all right let's get let's talk about
more about revenue i'm guessing you guys
have questions let's
let's just look let's just review top
earning videos in the last 365
days this blender one of course the ones
you saw at the top
oh the land the job the joshua fluke
mindset flaw
is still getting views that video is
really old at this point
i'm surprised it still gets views but i
don't know some people like to
totally uh seem to like it so yeah here
we go let's see
so yeah i i guess i make
um it didn't start out well i guess you
can see it all right here starting in
july
let's just see more this is all of it so
i got monetized in may and that's when i
hit about a thousand subs you gotta hit
a thousand subs to potentially get
monetized
youtube reviews your channel they
reviewed my channel they said all right
you're fine let's
go ahead and monetize you and i said
thanks
or whatever you know and i started
making about 50 bucks a month just for
my pre-existing videos which were in the
hundreds
or 100 i don't know it was a lot and
then it just kind of starts steadily
ramping up as long as i continue to make
content now i have noticed that if i
don't make content this number starts
dropping off so um
yeah i really like doing this i really
want to keep doing it and i want this to
just keep kind of growing a little bit
and hopefully bring
new opportunities for me and my family
where
you know being in this pandemic era
we're in it's great to be able to stay
at home most of the time and work
uh which is what i tend to do but uh
hopefully
it can get to a point where this channel
is is the main thing
and it's uh it's pretty close to that
right now i guess
closer than a lot of my other projects
anyway
so i'm pretty happy with that but let's
talk about more than just
revenue
let's look at some more random things
and i guess another kind of random thing
is
i didn't produce any videos for like
three months and then i just started
making them again
is that accurate was it really that big
of a gap i don't
i don't exactly recall what was i doing
in this period i don't know
and i just started making videos again
at some point i was just like yeah i'm
back on the back on the bus
i honestly don't remember because this
looks like all time
lifetime i'm just curious here what
happened no it just doesn't show the old
ones
or something i'm not sure but i was i
was definitely like posting videos
some back here so there should be
something
i don't know maybe this is a little a
little bugged or something
but uh yeah there we go most of my
viewers
are on at noon interesting
and there's all kinds of stats here that
are kind of cool to look at maybe you
guys might like to see
uh yeah here we go this one this one i
always
you know when i'm watching other
youtubers and stuff when they show these
numbers those are
way better than mine and they're
complaining but watch time watch time
form subscribers
95.8 so basically 96 of people are not
subscribed that watch my channel and
only four percent
are and i see people with like
20 subscribe complaining
i don't know should i complain about
this yeah definitely subscribe i
i get a ton more subscribers than i
suspect expect already so
i'm not trying to be greedy here
um but yeah please do subscribe it does
mean a lot
uh but i'm not gonna harass you anymore
you see the numbers
i see the numbers if other youtubers are
complaining when it's not even close to
that bad maybe i should too
no i don't like i don't like listening
to other youtubers or people in general
i'm kidding i like listening to some
people just
all right i guess it goes into the whole
negativity thing like
all right serious conversation and this
is a rant off top of my head so if it
comes out bad i'm
i'm sorry but i'm going to do my best to
explain here
negativity is tricky it is really easy
to get in a negative loop and being that
we're going into a new year i think it's
really important that
we kind of like reset and
get out of our old ruts that we were
stuck in that's how i like to
address new year's anyway as i try to
sort of reset some things i am doing
that with a lot of stuff
a lot of stuff you don't see on this
channel like a lot of stuff going on in
my personal life right now i am changing
um in a pretty big way uh but you guys
won't really see that here it's just
it's gonna make it easier for me to be
more consistent so
the big things are doing is i'm making a
like a
pretty well permanent schedule for
myself and i have a bunch of other like
little side projects that are
not related to this channel much
so i'm not going to like mention them
specifically in link or anything it's
not about that
but i have a lot of other stuff going on
and i'm trying to make time for that too
because it is important
and it is relevant and it's like family
stuff and my own personal projects
and my own personal business
here locally where i do a lot of
computer stuff and
you know try to get contracts and stuff
like that but also
trying to make a game this year and i've
got a really great design in my head
that i love but i don't want to share it
yet because it's a bit early to be
sharing that i don't know if i'm going
to do it on the channel before i'm going
to do it on my personal channel
but the point of all this is i guess you
you just
you just got to let the the negative
people get drowned out um
you know i get a decent amount of
comments uh three or four a day at least
usually sometimes a little less
sometimes a little more
and i want to say like 90 of them are
fine
like there's probably 50 percent that
are like a thanks and
you know and stuff like that and i
really appreciate those sorry if i don't
reply or hurt all of them
uh i try to but sometimes i miss them
but i do really appreciate that you guys
appreciate that i'm you know spending my
time doing this
and there's also a good chunk of them
that are just technical questions
and now i want to address this this is
this is important let me go to my
comments
i guess i'm upside down this that's fine
i'm upside down all right so
i mean let's just look at some random
comments here uh
i don't know website let's just let's do
this one
here we go all right
so let's let me just use these as a
example
um i'll start out here and just go
through some
uh i don't know where to start okay a
lot of people
commenting on the cmake tutorials as
they do get the most views some of the
most views so that's kind of natural
um a lot of people kind of like making
yeah this episode episode two in general
i like
honestly i whiffed it i uh i wish i
wish i redid it before i posted it
because like i
i blundered that sucker so bad but
people seem to get it
and it does seem to still help people so
i was trying to like
make it in a way where you could like
learn learn from the mistakes i was
making in the video and because i like
fixed them later in the video and stuff
and they were just little stuff like
making sure i had the variable names
right so it wasn't anything huge
uh but it did confuse some people and i
get a lot of questions saying
or a lot of comments saying oh here's
how you fix the stuff
and uh yeah i know now it's
uh sometimes you just got to get your
videos done you can't spend
all month on them all week on them you
just kind of got to get what
you just got to release what you got
sometimes and that's kind of how that
was at that time
so sorry if it is confusing i hope it
was a good learning experience it seemed
to be
so thank you for all the comments and
all that uh
oh but you know it's good even if you're
leaving these comments from me and i
don't really address them
there's probably other people watching
the video that find them helpful so
thank you still
that does mean a lot thanks carlos uh
here's like another one
all right i am going to make an example
out of these and talk about all these um
that's the point here uh i'm not really
interested in ogre next as i'm starting
with graphics but more 1.12 would be
great trying to figure it all out myself
thanks okay that's on the over 3d
rendering which seemed to get
quite a few views and attention people
did seem to appreciate that i don't know
if i'm going to
go further with ogre i might i guess
we'll figure it out later
um there seems to be more demand for
other things
and i've sort of moved past it for now
but i might i might come back to it if
there's anything big
all right and on this old linker library
video the one i was talking about
earlier that gets like mostly downvotes
can you please tell me how to add
libraries in vs code
2020.
this wouldn't be a bad video to make
there's a couple of different ways you
can do it i don't use vs code a ton but
i did figure this out on my own and it
is kind of it is way more complicated
than it needs to be to be honest
so i might make a video on that point on
that uh
yeah about this comment about how to use
vs code not visual studio community
edition but
actually bs code now one thing you can
do is you can use
vc package manager and
when you set it up to link it on your
computer
or do the integrate install part it
gives you a cmake command so you can use
that cma command to point to all your
libraries so
and then if you're using visual studio
code that's fine it works with cmake
so by integrating cmake you can pretty
easily get access to your libraries
and let me know if you want a video on
that i could do a video on that that
might be a good one to do it is
a little bit confusing to be honest it
took me like way too long to figure that
out one day
uh because you couldn't just there was
more to it than
i just said basically while there
shouldn't be there just was because
that's how this coding stuff works
apparently all right here's another one
from my avoid coding burnout
advice from c plus plus isn't this more
of how to be a better programmer than
avoiding burnout
i guess it would be both because yeah if
you're avoiding burnout you're
definitely going to be a better
programmer because you're keeping on it
so this is more about keeping on it
and not stopping so again yeah
yeah if you if you follow his advice you
will be better programmer and you'll
probably also avoid burnout so
i don't know if it's more of one or the
other but cool
um let's see could you teach me how to
write a text editor on the vc
package manager live video uh
i don't know that might be a cool
project thing to do at some point text
editor
maybe so these are the general comments
okay we've got a cool
thanks no problem awesome okay and oh
yeah the comments on the land the job
the joshua
fluke mindset flaw are great some of
them are like people that are really
really bitter and mad some of them are
cool they're just such a giant variety
of people just spilling their beans and
guts and these comments i love reading
them
i usually don't respond to them anymore
just because it's like such an old video
and usually it's just like
uh do i really have to address this
again because i've sort of like in some
way or another's
talked about most of these but i'll talk
about this one because it's on the video
spent 45 years working in a variety of
companies large and small
most either have employed i'm gonna make
this bigger sorry
guys sorry if i'm making this
complicated okay
so marty 88-ish 45 years
working at big and small companies most
have either employers or co-workers that
bring their personal crap to work and
use it as an excuse to bully other
people
whoa let's just stop right there okay
well yes every individual person you me
your neighbor every everyone you know
has
personal crap going on and
sure you're not supposed to bring it to
work but it's with you all the time
whether you
like it or not it's just the human
condition is we have
to deal with our stuff okay but here's
where i see an issue
use it as an excuse to bully other
people
most most people bring their personal
crap to work
and use it as an excuse to bully other
people
now leave a comment on this if you want
but
here's my take on that
that's not true well i guess it depends
on the environment if you're working in
like really
toxic environments this might be a lot
worse and most might fit here
but in my experience and i've worked a
fair share of crappy jobs and
jobs i would consider pretty good so
i've been all the way in between between
like you know crappy jobs to good jobs
and yes people do bring their personal
crap to work
if they're like bullying people with it
though you just don't stand for that
stuff you just call them out that's all
you got to do it usually works
maybe they'll get mad at you but oh what
you get to go find a better job
there's not a bunch of nonsense drama
great
you know it's a win-win situation you've
got to call them out i'll tell you a
story
i'll tell you a little story about this
that i have
uh you might enjoy it
okay so i was working before i went to
college i was working out of
uh let me think how to kind of uh
give you the context here without
revealing too much of my personal life
okay there was a point in my life where
i was playing a lot of guitar and bass
and writing a lot of songs
and i was basically trying to make it as
a musician and
i got you know i was in a band we were
touring
everything was going decent uh other
than you know
it was it's a grind being in a band is a
massive grind and it was definitely
going somewhere given enough time
uh but at some point the band basically
broke up
at that point i uh
i don't know i was kind of in a rut for
a while we'll say so i was just like all
right i'll just take whatever job for
now
get back on my feet and it that was fine
so i had a job at a pizza place for a
while
and it was a relatively short-lived job
it wasn't something i was planning on
doing permanently it was like i'm
basically just going to do this till i
get another it job or something like
that i hadn't gone to college i did not
have a college degree
i wasn't being a computer scientist
wasn't even on my radar at that point so
just to give you a little context for
where i was in my life i was not a
programmer yet in this story
so i was working at this pizza place and
uh there was this girl there and we kind
of started dating
a little bit and her ex-boyfriend also
worked there
and her ex boyfriend was basically a
complete jerk
like i don't know i didn't get his
mindset he was he was sort of uh
he was a lifer like at that company like
he wasn't aspiring to ever
really go anywhere else or anything like
that well now that's a bad thing
but just to give you a context for kind
of his mindset and the type of person he
was
it wasn't exactly someone that wasn't
trying to improve their life
so i didn't see a lot in the guy like i
wasn't gonna try to befriend him and be
like
hey let's work on stuff together or
anything like that because it just
wasn't that sort of person he was like
in his own world
drank a lot of beer showed up at work
harassed people generally
just an obnoxious person and i didn't
particularly like the guy but i like you
know i just kind of ignored him and did
my job
because i didn't really care i don't
really like getting involved in drama in
general
but one day he like walked into work and
just started like slamming stuff like
throwing boxes throwing stuff around
slamming things on tables just like
obviously like losing his mind
and i was just sitting there and like
looking at him like what are you doing
so it's really vague to me
uh actually but apparently i i don't
remember what i said
but i just sort i just said something to
him and i don't i really don't
wish someone else would know someone
else that was working there would know
because they all like were really
surprised that i just kind of stood up
to him but
i don't really people don't really scare
me like if someone
came at me all crazy i would just handle
it and move on about my life i try not
to let people bother me
so i basically i wish i remember what i
said or i had recorded or something but
no one was recording
but basically i said something like i
just
i didn't do it in a rude way either i or
i tried not to i was like yo right man
it seemed like you're kind of losing it
there or something like that
you know i just kind of just called it
out and he stopped
he like settled down and took a breath
and stopped doing his flip out thing
and there were a lot less problems with
him after that
and i didn't do anything that drastic i
was just like the one person who would
actually say something to him because
everyone else was afraid of him
so the point is you should just say
something
if someone's really bothering you you
shouldn't let this happen if people are
bullying at work
you got to do something about if you're
not doing anything about it and you're
just like
oh that's just how it is people just you
know are terrible to each other and we
love it okay and we make
so well this can
so that's why i have a problem relating
to this comment because i don't put up
with this kind of stuff
like if someone is like this way around
me
that's like a red flag that management
or something that is not
necessarily the greatest company to work
for or
you at least need to do your part and
try to change it if you're not doing
that then
i don't know that's a rough world i'm
having i have a hard time relating with
those kind of people who
aren't progressive all right so using an
excuse to bully other people and make
their work environment
miserable it doesn't really matter how
nice or affable you are
trust me i don't trust you marty i think
you're probably pro one of these guys
doing it
so i'm gonna go with no
all right how is he so good
uh oh this is on the blender tutorial
okay well i'll give you a little tip
i spent three years editing videos for a
failed gaming channel and that's where i
got all my practice
nothing to show for other than i'm now
good at editing
blender with video but that channel that
i'm talking about that i edited for went
nowhere
so uh years and years of practice that's
that's how i got good
all right opengl part one i love this
tutorial new to c plus plus and you make
learned your cmake series and subscribe
cool thank you uh this is the first time
i was writing an open jail program can i
use opengl to write crap
claw cross-platform programs like
sublime
text i guess you could um
yeah i don't know i might just have to
do some video on that later but i got to
do some research before i just start
saying stuff
i'm sure you can but to have like a
graphics
accelerated text editor seems weird to
me
i don't know if that's i don't know if
opengl is necessarily the best
uh technology to use make a text editor
but then again i would have to do some
research
all right this guy looks like guilfoyle
from silicon valley
joke's part he explained great ah cool
thanks hi
i get that a lot people seem to think i
like look like kilfoil
i also get jesus a lot which is fine i
don't i don't mind if i look like people
like
i don't get offended by that or anything
in fact
the last job one of the last jobs i
worked at
that's how everyone recognized me they
literally they were like
there was a sub the people that were
like not in my department
just uh they were like oh new programmer
that got hired that looks like jesus the
guy that looks like i was the guy that
looks like jesus
and they the first time i've like went
and played d and d with him one night
and it was a great time and a great
group of people
but one of them was like i hope this
doesn't offend you but we literally
knew you as the guy that was like the
new guy that looks like jesus
because you know there were new guys
every once in a while but i guess
and i was like no not at all chris so i
just think it's funny
i guess i don't know it doesn't
particularly do me any good to look like
guilfoyle or jesus other than
you know it's not something i do on
purpose or think about it's just i guess
a coincidence
i don't know if i really look like them
that much do i
no beside this i don't know whatever it
doesn't matter
all right what do i get for my two bonus
points use sir get a heart
there you go that's what you got for
your two bonus points congratulations
all right part two huge oh this is
and there's also just a whole a giant
slew of
weird comments that don't make any sense
at all
like this one from hugh jordan1 congrats
you have been drafted into my fifth
youtuber tournament well 50 players will
compete to be number one each round
a five player five players will be
eliminated but the final round one of
the finalists will become the tournament
five
champion what what is what is this even
about i don't know what you're talking
about
um but he has some subs maybe he gets
subs by leaving this comment people
wondering
i don't know i have no idea what that's
talking about you need
you need more context and why is
everything in caps
is this like a ai generated comment i
don't know
all right here's a new one how to set up
to code anything with visual studio
the vc package manager is a little bit
better than this
in my opinion but you can still do this
so
he's got some technical problems i read
this and i didn't really understand how
to answer them
so a lot of these technical questions i
would like to dig in
and research and answer them but if i
did it for every single one i would have
no time because
i don't know the problem with a lot of
these
and the reason i don't answer is yes
just because i don't know
and to figure it out i would have to ask
you a bunch of questions about what your
environment is and they don't have to
replicate your environment
they don't have to try to reproduce your
bug and
it would basically take like half a day
to answer any of these and who knows if
i'd even
be helpful i might just make it more
confusing so i generally don't answer
these unless i directly know the answer
so hopefully someone else in the
comments is able to help out ancient
phoenix in that video because i i'm not
sure
and unfortunately i i
you know i'm just at a loss there i hope
you're able to figure it out
that's just the way coding is sometimes
you just like get stuck on something and
you got to take some time and figure it
out and you can't find the answer online
that's actually very common
you can rarely find the answer online
unless it's like a
common problem all right transformations
great cool
so that's like that's a pretty good like
idea of the kind of comments i get on a
regular
is just this type of stuff
and as you can see that's kind of why i
don't respond to all of it because a lot
of it's just like i don't even know what
to say
i really don't but i do really
appreciate the comments they're cool to
read
it's neat to see other personalities get
involved and
stuff like that uh
are we going off the rails on this uh
year in review i feel like we are but
that's okay let's get back on the reels
let's talk about a few more things and
then we'll close it out
okay so we are now back on social blade
just taking a quick look at things hey
looks like
we're nearing the top hundred thousand
in the how to video
rank so that's good as channel wise
greatest c
plus i don't really know that it should
be c plus plus am i right
um all right well
uh yeah i don't know exactly what to
make of these numbers but this one seems
pretty good
i guess is it good there's a lot of
youtubers i don't know it's hard to
it's hard to really assess uh these
estimated
earnings are semi-close i guess
not really i don't know i guess i did
say it earlier
it's around 100 a month right now
usually yearly earnings yeah expected
you know if it stays 100 it's going to
be about
uh 1 200 a year
which it's not close enough to survive
on but it does help and it is cool to
have a little side hustle going
on um
yeah i know i have adblock on you can
see it down here
i don't always have it on usually when i
watch youtube i try to keep it off
but some ads are just so invasive and
pop up in your face and
yell at you and turn your audio on uh so
it's so frustrating to
add so i get it if people use adblock
please whitelist my channel though that
would mean a lot
um so subscribers weekly let's look at
this this is cool this is really cool to
see
now this does correlate pretty directly
with views
um but as you can see like beginning of
last year
i was getting like i don't know about 10
subs a week
and then like after a while once some of
the videos started taking off a little
bit more
i started getting like about 10 a day
which is crazy
to me i don't know where you guys are
coming from
but i love you all all right
and yeah this this graph correlates
almost directly with the number of views
so the more views you can manage to pull
in the more subs you're going to get
in general uh i guess that's like the
take away from these graphs and that
i've heard that from other people too
that seems to be true
so if you're trying to grow a channel i
guess just got to try to get views i
don't really
i don't know i don't really think about
that too much
i just kind of make videos and try to
make them as good as i can for the
moment
so i don't really think too much about
the views to be honest
i have 204 uploads so hopefully by
this time next year this will say like
307 or something
so hopefully we can keep on track and
here we go here's like the daily stuff i
don't know if that's relevant for the
end of the year but
yeah i just want to say thanks guys it's
let me get to the other screen
it's really been quite a ride i got a
lot of coding videos coming up i got
some new tutorials
uh coming up about video editing too i
think i'm going to start diving into
davinci a little bit i've been using
davinci
to edit my videos recently and i've kind
of gone back and forth between davinci
and blender i still really like blender
i can't i can't deny that sometimes
blender is just really easy
to for me because i'm so used to it to
just load things up
do a few things and call it a day da
vinci i got to do a lot more
figuring out stuff but davinci is really
nice
and i think it's more popular and it's
also just made for video editing
where blender is not so i think it makes
sense to actually talk about a real
video editor and dig into that some this
year so i plan on doing a bit of a
series on that
i still have a lot to learn i don't want
to dive in too soon before i'm too much
of a noob like i did with my vim
tutorial that
no one seemed to like because you're
like you're not even saying this the
term's right
uh and stuff like that yeah
it's still up there i don't know i just
i just wong it
it's but uh so i'm trying to avoid
making tutorials and stuff that i don't
necessarily understand well enough but
there were definitely a lot of times
where i was just like i just need to get
some kind of video out
i'm kind of don't have a whole lot of
ideas i know how to do this let's just
do this real quick
so let me know what you guys think down
below sure do appreciate you guys
hope you have a great new year let me
know what your resolutions are
hopefully it's coding lots let's do a
lot of coding this year
i want to do some more live streams too
i guess i haven't talked about that but
i kind of cut off the live streams
because they were basically just too
stressful
um that's the only way i can really
think of it is they were just too
stressful
i don't know something about streaming
code kind of triggers me
and i i don't really know what to do
about that
i can't help that it like triggers me
really i mean i can like suppress it
for a while but eventually it's going to
come out you know
and i i think it's just that like
i just feel like every bit of thing i
type
everybody's analyzing and being like oh
no no do it this way and
i just i don't know i guess i just don't
like backseat drivers is what it comes
down to
but i'm trying to get over that and be a
better person about that and you know
so that's something i got to work on we
all have things to work on
all right peace out guys happy new year
let's have a great year